i'm outside with the legends and robbers
you out here doing videos and leggings
and joggers
gorilla nims i'm the [__]
hardest from brooklyn to la like the
dodgers remarking now we on the road
doing big shows for dollars after party
at the strip club we dick hold that
swallow you want smoke it'll be a [__]
show i promise bounce your head off the
pavement like a six foe impala
now we moving at the speed of light get
money stay solid and quiet that's the
key to life come to my block whatever
you want for a decent price my shooters
can name every gun but can't read or
write yeah homie i'm really linkedin
you're a professional dick sucker add
that to your linkedin acts around the
heart they'll tell you i've really been
him and i'll break your [__] jaw like
you had a thin chin come to your block
set up shop then we tie it down package
it up then distribute it either white or
brown coney island is the lavish now
life lifestyle